hello welcome to science breakthroughs
from science mission I am sadashiva pi
and going to discuss couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of july twenty first let's start
first we will discuss a paper published
by Lutha Ishimura in science on the role
of trna in neurodegeneration why is this
paper so important role of translational
machinery in neurodegenerative diseases
is not known authors demonstrate a point
mutation in trna NTR 20 leads to
cerebellar ataxia introducing in TR 22
mouse with the disease blocks said that
let us look at the data authors observed
progressive apoptosis of neurons in the
inner granular layer of n FF 205 meat
and cerebellum in week 3 and the animals
died in eight to nine weeks of age with
ataxia apoptosis was also observed in
dentate gyrus ca2 pyramidal neurons
layer for cortical neurons and retinal
photoreceptors western blot analysis of
mutant cerebellar extract failed to
detect protein GTP bp2 as authors
identified the NFF 205 mutation as a
point mutation in the intron 6 of gtp
bb2 gene that results in misplaced mrnas
with the premature stop codons pelota
was immunoprecipitated by GTP be p2 and
ght gtp BP to fusion also pull down
pelota from grain extracts which
demonstrated that gtp pb2 can interact
with endogenous pelota authors
identified a mutation till to see in NTR
t20 gene of v6j strain at the nucleotide
50 of trna t stem which when processed
her into 105 nucleotide product rather
than normal 1 15 nucleotides as shown in
this figure
when wild-type in TR 20 was expressed in
n ff- mouse the cerebellar and retinas
death was rescued after six months as
shown thereby confirming the role of
tRNA in neurodegeneration expression of
NTR 20 and it's human ortholog were
confined to cns its level fell 50 % @ p
0 to 30 % @ p 30 with the concomitant
increase in unprocessed tRNAs also be j6
strain had higher level of unprocessed
trna in cerebellum than cortex and
hippocampus others also found that
number of AGA passes increase
dramatically in b6 j NM f 350 negative
cerebellum unusual AGA passing was not
observed in cerebellar libraries with
NTR 20 compared to be 6 j & B 6 j NM f
205 deleted cerebella indicating
ribosome passing during translation
occurs specifically at aga codons so
others identify a translation mechanism
for neuro degeneration next let's look
into a paper published by chiara manzini
and colleagues in cell reports authors
demonstrate that control of human
intellectual and social functions by CC
to be 1a why is this paper so important
genetic variants of autism spectrum
disorder and intellectual disability
with some identical physical traits are
not clearly understood authors identify
coiled-coil and c2 domain containing one
knee that is CC 2d 18 gene mutations in
families with diverse intellectual and
social disabilities authors demonstrate
that reduced dendritic complexities in
CC to d1
of neurons and were rescued with NF
Kappa B inhibitors Earth's form for
families with the total of sixteen
individuals affected by spectrum of
cognitive and social impairments
including a HD and s ID and seizure
Jenner genomic analysis and further
sequencing revealed g2g mutation in
three or four families and a deletion in
the fourth family on CC to d1 a gene
complete exclusion of exon 6 we seen in
family one when analyzed for cc to d1 a
mrna western blot analysis of patients
align showed reduced CC to d1 a
expression in heterozygous carrier and
complete absence of CC 2d one year in
the patient either in the full length or
truncated form showing that this
mutation is null a simplified dendritic
Arbor was observed in cortical neurons
after electroporation of shrna at P
Levin reduced dendritic complexity was
also evident in CC to d1 a knockout
hippocampal neurons and dendritic spine
density was significantly reduced but
synaptic density remain unchanged cc2
d1a overexpression caused significant
activation of nf-kappa b than other
pathways while CC to d1 be
overexpression did not elicit an
increase in NF kappa b activation
indicating that NF kappa b activation is
specific to CC to d1 a no effect of CC
to d1 a depletion of NS kappa b at early
differentiation but NF kappa b
activation was moderately and
significantly increased about control
conditions during the peak dendrite
extension at seven division in CC to the
1n knockout neurons treatment with s and
50 peptide inhibitor and JH 23
small-molecule inhibitor
but not in active control peptide SN 50m
rescue dendritic complexity in CC 2d one
AR ni treated cells this study
demonstrate a role for cc to d1 a in
human intellectual and social ability
thank you for watching science
breakthroughs from science mission